so y'all are doing a lot you're doing
the 50 City Tour you're planning the
wedding I heard you recently you were
just in a car accident right we are
doing a lot yeah I'm like you were just
in a car accident like are you okay like
it was very um it was very very scary
um and there's a lot going on in your
world it was a wild time and
unfortunately Haley got you know super
injured you know head injury but you
know I say that she's like Wolverine she
heals so fast it's unbelievable I do
like healthy that's what happens that's
your gift I was also a really good
patient I was really on top of taking
care of myself like icing constantly so
I did all the right things I'm so
grateful to be okay that we're okay and
were y'all sliding right is that what I
heard like it was like in snow
it was very it was very scary and I
would say the love from everybody that
reached out thank you so much it was
been so kind and um but also it made you
just think about just life you know and
just how precious it is really
um with someone that can be taken so
quickly so fast and so honestly all
these experience is that we share
together and going out on the road and
sharing them with you know people in
their cities yeah like I said I haven't
been there in four years like we're just
we just cannot wait for this year and
it's and then getting married so many
beautiful things that's great
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]